in washington dc
a wave of opposition trump is stealing
the election
[Applause]
a march with a message for the president
get the hell out of the white house
get out of town you're not welcome here
he should stand down
he should want he should watch his back
because everybody's coming for him
the resentment isn't new a day after
donald trump's inauguration in 2017
record numbers gathered across the u.s
to voice their anger
today they rallied once more for them
four more years isn't an option we are
going to afford into power an
administration
that we can hold accountable that will
listen to us and that will
actually listen to the agenda of the
american people
what would donald trump need to say or
do to change your mind
nothing he is somebody
of questionable values and ethics
he has had ample opportunity over the
last three and a half years
to show us the type of person he is
we've seen it
we have paid attention and we we have
said we've had enough of him
current polls still show joe biden ahead
and it's suburban women that could be a
major obstacle
to trump reentering the white house
suburban women will you please like me
in pennsylvania this week the president
tried to get women on side
i saved your damn neighborhood okay but
his nomination of amy coney barrett to
the supreme court has left many fearing
abortion rights are under threat today
anger bubbled over as pro and anti
faced off he's the most pro-life
president we've ever had so i am
in support of it and i am supportive his
policy
for both sides the time for action is
running out
it's votes not loud voices which will
decide america's future
siobhan robbins sky news washington